donc vous avez le contact avec ce type
qui est ami qui vous parle et pendant
qu'il vous parle vous entendez qu'en
fait il est il est il est dépecé
bonne soirée bienvenue merci alors vous
êtes rwandaise survivant du génocide
toute votre famille a été massacrée et
vous vous battez pour qu'on n'oublie pas
ce qui s'est passé là-bas vous publiez
chez Michel Lafont un livre qui
s'appelle nous existons encore avec une
préface d'André Glucksmann alors
Glucksman dit dans sa préface l'idée de
l'homme c'est à nouveau fracassé dans
les abattoirs du Rwanda comment écrire
penser aimer après Auschwitz on pourrait
dire comment penser écrire aimer après
le Rwanda car c'est un génocide comme
celui qui a eu lieu au Cambodge où celui
qui a eu lieu en Allemagne pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale alors
génocide parce que les Tutsis ont été
éliminés pour la simple raison qu'ils
étaient toutes si il y avait pas
d'autres raisons les Hutus tu
méthodiquement les Tutsis vous dites ils
éradiquent les cafards c'est ça
c'était d'une part la grande majorité de
la population autour encadrée par des
militaires et des musiciens qui avaient
été formés pour ça qu'il y avait creusé
des fausses communes pour ça et c'était
une nuitée jour et après ils abattent
près des fausses communes parce que
c'est plus simple de tuer les gens
auprès des fosses communes tout
simplement pour
tous les tuer comme ils disent et à la
moitié du génocide en avril comme pour
ma famille à moi ma femme était tué le
30 avril là il ne tuait plus près des
fausses dans des maisons mais près des
fosses communes ça se voyait moins ça
donnait moins de travail aussi alors la
communauté internationale le sait et ne
fait rien du tout
euh vous et votre famille le savez et
vous ne partez pas on pouvait partir on
ne part pas parce que on n'avait pas de
voiture chez moi c'est une violence
incroyable puisque quand les Hutus tuent
votre oncle ils épargnent votre temps
pour qu'elle meurt de chagrin si c'est
quand même on se demande
ce comporter comme ça
et bouleversant il y a des il y a des
bébés qui sont qui sont découpés à la
machette qui sont tués qui sont
éventrées pour l'histoire de mon oncle
de ma tante j'en parle beaucoup dans le
livre parce que c'était ma mes cousines
préférées ils avaient huit filles et un
garçon il y en a une de leurs filles qui
est morte chez nous et ils ont tué donc
tout enfin ils n'ont pas tué les enfants
et leur couper les temps d'Achille et
ils ont tué l'encre ils ont laissé ma
tante pour qu'elle meurt de faim et une
semaine après ils ont ma tante et ses
enfants ont été brûlés dans une église
pas très loin parce que là aussi il
tuait dans des maisons mais la plupart
du temps ils regroupait dans des églises
dans des stades et ils tiraient dans la
foule et après
barbarie un tel endoctrinement des gens
on y est arrivé comme on est un peu
arrivé j'imagine à faire le génocide des
Juifs en Europe en les années 40
pendant des années des années à Dieu
Mille Collines les journaux
c'est le non c'est c'est la propagande
on était des cafards depuis
toujours
de l'ONU ils sont restés complètement
impuissants et personne n'a bougé parce
qu'on a retiré le la Belgique à retirer
c'était la plus grosse équipe et il y a
eu 10 casques bleus qui ont été tués dès
les premiers jours avec
le Premier ministre et ils ont retiré la
Belgique quand ils étaient de retirer
ces il en reste plus que 500 et quelques
hommes de de l'ONU mais pour cela moi je
ne dis rien parce qu'ils ont quand même
essayé de faire ce qu'ils ont pu avec le
peu de moyens qu'ils avaient par contre
s'ils avaient vraiment voulu arrêter le
génocide c'était vraiment très très
simple parce qu'il fallait ne serait-ce
que monopoliser la radio des Mille
Collines ou interdire le
gouvernement intérimaire enfin il y
avait le moyen d'arrêter moi je pensais
pas quand je suis arrivée en France
c'est la première fois où j'ai vu les
images du génocide je n'aurais jamais
cru que la terre entière était au
courant
des complicités de pouvoir occidentaux
quand il y a eu l'assassinat du
président de la République avec les
roquettes tout ça est en train de sortir
puisque un de ceux qui a dénoncé cette
affaire à témoigner la semaine passée
devant le tribunal pénal Da Rocha qui
traite du génocide du Rwanda donc c'est
ce sont des choses qui va falloir
dénoncer les États-Unis en un rôle la
c'est un rôle tous les grands pays ont
eu un rôle dans cette affaire et on
laissait faire et ça ce qui est
absolument inacceptable parce que tous
les jeunes sites se sont passés de la
même manière et ça c'est depuis
l'Arménie les Juifs les Tziganes les
Cambodgiens
les toussis et c'est chaque fois le même
processus auquel on assiste et personne
ne réagit et ce qui est dramatique c'est
que en même temps les victimes se
retrouvent encore plus victimes parce
que personne leur dit réagissait
battez-vous défendez-vous et ça c'est
chaque fois le même c'est le même
phénomène pour se défendre c'est très
compliqué parce que comment se défendre
quand il n'y a pas de toute il
n'allaient pas dans l'armée ils
n'étaient pas dans l'administration on a
on a pu se rendre compte enfin moi je
peux me rendre compte mais avec du recul
que la population tout était préparée
alors vous vous retrouvez vous vous
retrouvez un jour donc 5 enfants et une
femme face à des civils armées de
machettes de gourdin cloutés de robinet
à arracher au mur enfin vraiment une
espèce de foule comme ça et rectante
votre mère à la tête fracassée elle est
terminée à la baïonnette vous voyez
votre mère se faire enfoncer dans dans
la poitrine une baïonnette les cadavres
sont dépouillés de leur bijoux les morts
et les vivants sont jetés pêle-mêle et
les uns sur les autres enfin c'est un
récit absolument abominable
effectivement et là en ce qui vous
concerne en tous les cas miracle le
camion s'en va avec tous les cadavres
vous restez là vous vous rendez compte
que le camion est parti et là vous
faites passer pour une ou tout je
reconnais à peu près un type que je
voyais à une barrière pas très loin de
chez moi et je lui dis mais vous vous me
reconnaissez quand même parce que et il
voit bien il croit reconnaître ma tête
et je raconte que mon père vient du nord
c'était le patient
des huttos extrémistes et il dit oui je
crois que je te connais et ils me disent
mais on va partir vérifier
à la commune ça fait la commune
si tu es bien où tout est donc eux ils
partent effectivement vont vérifier à la
commune et ils reviennent le lendemain
et en attendant j'étais resté chez un
collègue de ma mère qui nous avait déjà
dénoncé la veille et qui me redonne au
militaire et là c'est encore un coup de
se passer la chance ou quoi que ce soit
parce que j'en mérite pas plus que
d'autres mais
vous restez en vie mais c'était
épouvantable parce que vous êtes obligé
de nettoyer le bureau ou votre mère a
été massacrée c'est-à-dire il y a du
sang partout visqueux vous êtes obligé
de nettoyer il y a cette odeur de mort
et finalement enfin vous vous survivez
mais dans des conditions épouvantables
on vous raconte que votre mère a été
dépecée par par des chiens et
par la femme de ces de ce de ce collègue
de ma mère qui elle se baladait parce
que la vie pour les autos elle
continuait normalement vous allez au
marché ils allaient se rendre visite et
une fois elle est revenue elle m'a dit
mais ta mère elle est elle est en train
de se faire manger par des chiens je
pense que elle ce qu'elle voulait
c'était que moi je me mette en danger
toute seule parce que la deuxième fois
j'étais sauvée par un militaire et ils
étaient trop lâches pour me
faire tuer eux-mêmes parce que j'avais
peur que le militaire demande des
comptes un jour et je pense que dans le
fond elle voulait que quelque part
j'aille voir ne serait-ce que pour la
couvrir ou n'importe quoi il y a une
scène qui est enfin on s'arrêtera là un
jour c'est Victor qui vous parle à
travers une porte donc vous avez le
contact avec ce type qui est ami qui
vous parle et pendant qu'il vous parle
vous entendez qu'en fait il est il est
il est dépecé
il est dépecé pendant qu'il lui parle et
un moment vous entendez une espèce de
crier épouvantable un hurlement de la
mort et vous comprenez que que ce Victor
est en train d'être dépecé de l'autre
côté oui en fait le Victor était venu se
cacher dans l'école ils peuvent nous
dans notre famille pour pas nous mettre
en danger et trois jours après la mort
de ma mère il vient demander de l'aide à
son collègue parce que lui aussi
travailler
à l'école et le mec qui chez qui j'étais
il est passé derrière la maison pour
appeler les veilleurs de nuit qui sont
venus tuer Victor là encore le couple
collègue de ma mère ils m'ont sorti à
côté de ce qui tu es Victor je pense
pour que aussi là je me fasse tuer mais
je me suis pas fait tuer ça a duré
pas une éternité mais ça a duré
longtemps et après il s'est mis à hurler
ils l'ont enterré pas totalement mort
encore il est mort dans la matinée donc
c'est un livre qu'il faut lire parce que
effectivement c'est c'est sur la
barbarie humaine c'est pratiquement
indépassable un million de victimes en
100 jours
1 million de victimes en 100 jours
sans compter les gens qui sont
traumatisés handicapés contaminés par le
sida lors de viol évidemment parce que
ceux qui meurt encore aujourd'hui parce
que les rescapés aujourd'hui se font
tuer pour ne pas témoigner pendant les
procès et il y en a encore énormément
qui se fait encore tuer aujourd'hui
la fin du génocide depuis 95 qui ferme
en 2008 qui a jugé à peu près 60
personnes et les derniers chiffres qui
sont qui ont été donnés par les
gouvernement rwandais c'est un peu plus
de 500000 tueurs mais tueurs directs
donc
c'est de ce système anglo-saxon
tout le monde doit aller faire l'épreuve
chacun va chercher les preuves de la
culpabilité ou l'innocence des personnes
donc ça prend un temps absolument
invraisemblable et les avocats qui sont
là commis d'office se retrouvent avec un
boulot absolument invrais c'est un
système de fou mais malgré tout c'est
quand même un vrai progrès parce que
c'est le Tribunal pénal international
par exemple dernièrement il y a le
ministre des Transports je vous disais
que enfin nos familles quand elles sont
faites tuées elles se transporter par
des camions des travaux publics le
ministre des Transports et le préfet
d'une ville qui ont été libérés pour
vice de forme quelque chose comme ça
la plupart sont passés à travers les
mailles du filet alors vous la chance
que vous avez c'est de survivre
évidemment vous arrivez en France des
hébergé dans la famille d'un pasteur
mais ça se passe pas très bien parce que
le pasteur on va pas épiloguer mais
essaye d'abuser de vous ensuite vous
êtes dans une famille d'accueil qui est
odieuse vous vous rendez compte que ces
gens-là ne recueillent des des réfugiés
que pour l'argent en fait mais malgré
tout vous vous battez vous obtenez la
nationalité française vous passez votre
votre permis de conduire vous allez à la
Sorbonne étudier et aujourd'hui j'ai
encore énormément de combats à mener
pour moi et pour pour les autres
alors il y a la justice on en parlait il
y a beaucoup de génocidaires au Rwanda
mais aussi à l'extérieur en France il y
en a énormément il y en a il y a jamais
eu un procès il y a une association qui
s'appelle le collectif des parties
civils pour le Rwanda qui essaie
d'obtenir des procès ou ne serait-ce
qu'un juge permanent pour s'occuper de
ces dossiers là ça ne marche pas
on a on vient de créer avec des amis une
association pour aider les rescapés les
enfants rescapés du génocide à aller à
l'école et on monte cette association là
qui s'appelle étude sans frontières
mission Rwanda parce qu'il y a aussi une
émission Tchétchénie c'était d'abord
pour le Rwanda vous avez passé votre vie
désormais à lutter pour qu'on n'oublie
pas le génocide du Rwanda je vais passer
une grosse partie de ma vie à lutter
pour qu'on n'oublie pas le génocide au
Rwanda parce qu'il reste encore
énormément de choses à faire
merci merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu